hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter two of both three of the
discourses
Epictetus is going to talk about what
one needs to study in order to become
one in greek is is how those kind of
ethos we might translate that as good
and Noble if we want to be very literal
but we would say in general a good
person somebody who has it together and
he picks out three main fields at oh boy
and in Greek of study that that person
needs to engage in now all of these are
dealt with by stoic philosophy the first
two by stoic ethics and the third by
stomach logic what he's concerned about
why he's bringing this up is something
that comes out as he continues his
discussion he says too many people are
jumping ahead to the third area and
focusing on epistemological issues
without having a good death achill
foundation so one of the things that's
involved in in this conception is that
if one doesn't have one's character at
least partly straightened out all the
epistemology that one does is not really
going to be particularly helpful same
thing with we might say critical
thinking a field that overlaps to
something
with epistemology so what are these
three here it is a study the first one
he says has to do with desires and
aversions that is our effective
orientations towards things that we take
to be good and our likewise are
effective orientation towards things
that we take to be bad we are desiring
things that are good that we think are
good we are averse to things that we
think are better now we don't always
desire the things that we want to we're
not always averse to the things we
thought to be diverse too so we get
these things mixed up walking with
terrible consequences or even just
slightly bad consequences to ourselves
so he thinks that it's very important to
study the nature of desire and aversion
and then what things that we want to
detach these two so this would encompass
questions like what is in our control
and what is not in our control because
for the Stoics our desires and our
versions ought to be restricted or
directed to those things that are
actually within our control we don't
want to be evaluating things that are
outside of our control
yeah is good and we're bad and that's
what desire and aversion to do he also
says that this includes the emotions and
well we'll see why when we come back to
it in just a moment the second has to do
with choices and rejections the the
Greek word is literally to choose
against you know awkward there's a [ __ ]
mate and awkward mate to choose know
Latin also has a similar verbal
structure in which you can you know you
have Vala for to choose to will and you
have no love to be unwilling to say no
to reject this is a little bit different
than desirous inversions this involves
the use of our Faculty of choice and we
do it on the basis of our desires and
aversions but we also can sometimes go
against them as well and we know better
right this area also encompasses just
like this one encompasses the emotions
this one
compasses the catacomb or what we
translate as duty or obligation
something very important for the Stoics
so those are the first two what is the
third the third has to do with avoidance
of error and rashness in judgment in
deciding about things yeah it's about
assent some kind of phases literally the
assets' the the the agreeing to things
now these are epistemological concerns
in that they're concerned with what we
want to believe and what we want not to
believe what we want to agree with and
what we ought to say yeah I'm not quite
so sure about that so Epictetus is
saying too many people focus on this
stuff and they don't give enough
attention to this so let's go back to
the first tier then we'll come back to
the third why is this so important well
one of our goals is to actually get what
we desire and one way you could do that
is to say well what are my desires how
can I go about getting them do some
means and reasoning and what gets left
out in that process figuring out whether
you have the right desires and aversions
in the first place because if you want
to be happy from the stoic perspective
you have to desire things that it is
realistic for you to expect to attain
that or you are going to be unhappy
right you're going to be experiencing
all sorts of emotions that are going to
be disturbances for you we want to avoid
the things that were averse to and part
of what this this study involves is
figuring out what we want to really be
averse to should we be averse for
example to illness should we see illness
as an evil or should we see it as
something that happens and then our own
reaction to inner feelings our opinions
those as being things that we can
exercise desire or aversion up starts
would say that's the case dealing with
emotions why is dealing with emotions
under this because emotions in large
part stem from the workings of our
desires and our
aversions so it says among these areas
of study the most important and
especially pressing is that which has to
do with the stronger emotions the
pathway the passions right for a strong
emotion does not arise except if a
desire fails to attain its object or an
aversion falls into what it would avoid
many of them are emotional compartments
not all only the Stoics don't reject all
emotions but many of our emotional
compartments are ultimately ultimately
irrational they involve some sort of
reasoning process some sort of process
of judgment but they get things wrong
and they can get things wrong because we
don't have our desires and aversions
lined up the way that we need them to be
if we're thinking about things in terms
of the stoic life so he says this is the
field of study which introduces to us
confusions tumults misfortunes and
calamities sorrows lamentations envies
and makes us envious and jealous
passions which make it impossible for us
to even listen to reason so it's very
important that we get that that sort of
thing right what about this second area
well in order for us to get our desires
and aversions right we're going to have
to choose some things that will probably
go against the desires that we have at
least for a while until we establish new
patterns of behavior new habits not only
behavior but also affect thinking
judging things all those those fit in
there so you know we need to learn how
to order those things rightly how to how
to set priorities how to see what's
really valuable and what's not so
valuable and to make ourselves align
ourselves with that with what we choose
when we reject acting carefully that's
important as well and on good reasons
you know we want to be doing things that
we can actually say make sense to
ourselves now he also talks about the
importance of maintaining our
relationship
crock relieved not only the natural
relationships but also the acquired or
relationships and here's what he says
that also ties in with emotions a little
bit the second field of study deals with
Duty for I ought not to be unlike a
statute but should maintain my relations
both natural and acquired as a religious
man has a son a brother or father
Danby says each of these roles as I've
talked about in another video reveals to
us certain obligations or certain duties
and some of these may in fact involve
feeling a certain way as well as acting
a certain way for the stoic so that's
another very important area of study the
third one involves attaining certainty
analyzing arguments that's why it's part
of the the logic study for them using
the criterion acquiring the criteria in
the first place all those sorts of
things and he goes on makes sense then
the third belongs to those who are
already making progress so it's not
something that one wants to jump into
and study for its own sake in a purely
theoretical manner
Epictetus over and over again says
that's not the point of stoic philosophy
so he goes something says it has to do
with the elements of certainty in
matters which have just been mentioned
now here's the ideal so that even in
dreams or in a state of drunkenness or
the state of melancholy a man may not be
taken unawares by the appearance of an
untested impression as translated your
sense impression an untested appearance
of Phantasia things that have that
reveal themselves to us that suggests
that they are the way that they are we
develop these resources these tools so
that when we're confronting things in
the outside world or inside of ourselves
we can say yeah that makes sense that
one I don't need to worry about that one
quite sure about so I'm going to
withhold assent from it for a while
until I get some better you know
evidence or grounds on one side or the
other it's much more important to get
this stuff right this is sort of the
icing on the cake according to Epictetus
yeah in these three fields of study so
you know he says philosophers passed by
the first and second fields of study
they concentrated by the third about
arguments syllogisms hypothetical
premises and sophisms and so what
happens well you're not really going to
make progress towards being a good and
noble person the last thing that I want
to bring up about this is there's a term
that I didn't put on the chalkboard but
which is quite important he says that
these are all not just told boy fields
of study but each one of them involves
discipline or ask a society uses the
verbal form they're asked a night which
means literally to engage in less cases
which means to engage in some sort of
training some sort of disciplining
activity so these are not just merely
theoretical studies they have to be
involved in application one he has to do
a lot of practice with them that also
implies that one will not fully
understand what is being taught until
one has made some progress
so moral progress along the way